Iterating over structures like ArrayLists is very important. So let's make sure
you've got this down. Let's return to the getFriends method. It was pretty
convenient that the two string method printed out almost exactly what we wanted
before. But how would we have printed the names of friends without the two
string method? Or what if we wanted to use a semicolon instead of a comma? let's
update the getFriends method so that it takes a string separator as a
parameter. It should still return a string. You should use the tester I wrote
to check your code. This method is a little bit like a sum over all the
elements, but you're putting together a string instead of a sum of numbers and
you'll need to be careful at the edges. You only want to print separators in
between names, you don't want to print one after the last name.